hello welcome to the Monday morning
review Thursday edition because here at
movieclips if we care about one thing
its brand consistency i am ryan and I'm
Sam and we're here to review the wolf of
Wall Street met Martin Scorsese's new
not so much review as gush about yeah i
chastise you for not having seen it yeah
and what do you have actually at you if
you have seen it and been chastise you
for not having seen it twice what's
wrong with it or not loving it enough
this is it can be described as nothing
less than magnum opus it is I think it
should be described that's less than
that because that implies that Scorsese
will never do a better movie yeah I I
still have hopes that he will continue
to do crazier and crazier yeah we spoke
about this and I i I'd spoken to other
people about this before speaking to you
at 71 years old the man has managed to
make one of the most energetic alive
movies I've seen in years and he
consistently does that if you look at
the department which was uh oh seven
years ago now and his 60 seemed a lovey
a younger younger younger no but even
then was secrecy if he's making movies
that that have the energy that young men
young even compete and honestly I think
there must be some kind of record here
in terms of drug use and sex being as
referenced you know as plotted against
age of director yeah this this is
probably there's more sex and more drugs
in this than in filth or in you know
Bronson or any of these sort of ya up
movies and ironically also more comedy
and higher it's a real mishmash of
things and kind of incredible I don't
just cuz we're gonna be talking about
Scorsese so much I don't want to
overlook how brilliant this brilliantly
written movie Terrence over who did
boardwalk empire um he wrote it and it
is an amazing screenplay even the actors
have been talking about how greedy oh
like what a document it was to work off
of so I just want to give a shout out
there but I mean Scorsese always and
throat you broke she doing um Scorsese I
mean every time he's making a movie
is the topic of coverage oh yeah there's
something about the idea of a guy that
age who has not you look at all the
directors he sort of came of age with
he's he's a little bit older than
Spielberg you know yeah the guys he was
working alongside of have kind of burned
out or they they do different movies or
they repeat themselves over and over
there's a guy who still every movie he
does is some insane stylistic change up
from everything he's ever done before
yeah Wally's while simultaneously
feeling signature yeah am sure is
amazing I think that the best example of
someone who was a flash in the pan is
someone that he's actually good friends
with which was Brian De Palma I was
gonna say saponin these guys who has
movies but they're they're they're a
young filmmaker imitating Brian De Palma
these guys who had insane amounts of
talent early on and kind of like flashed
in the pan and then kind of stop being
so interesting Scorsese has consistently
kept up and made these movies that are
amazingly artistic and pushed the
envelope while being commercially viable
yeah which is actually as possible that
he did so many drugs in the the mid to
late seventies to you know early 80s
that it has kept him moving at that page
yeah the forward momentum and I not let
up but I this let's talk about the
actual movie i I don't know there's that
much to talk about it's so it's so
spotless kind of theirs yeah not a lot
of I heard there's not at some point to
Caprio is explaining the nature of some
of his financial crimes and he just
turns to the camera seems like forget
about you know what you don't need to
know this get that it's a criminal
action
enough I the movie takes so many
interesting risks in terms of like the
audience is not there to watch you know
the progression we know Georgia where it
goes to jail for not a very long time
with yeah it's just about sort of
marinating in the weird you know
personalities that he surrounds us what
personalities they are like I I mean you
know DiCaprio was brilliant he's in
almost every frame of the movie Jonah
Hill is amazing and they have to they
have a couple of scenes there's two in
particular this one more Jonah Hill is
speaking about his wife / cousin um that
I cannot remember the last time I have
laughed so hard yeah be there and
there's a scene that a lot of people are
talking about the 11 the lemon 714 scene
there's this drug sequence that when
they do the real of Martin's corset em
and martin scorsese's memorial service
when they do the real of like his last
moments yeah martin scorsees hopefully
believe I let your years finally done
they do the highlight reel of all of his
best moments this will be up there with
the Gimme Shelter scene in Goodfellas
and so many seasons apart it's just
brilliant you know the interesting thing
that I've heard from a couple of
different sources and I you really don't
get a full sense of until you've sat on
the movie for a while yeah is how well
wolf of Wall Street sits with two movies
he made earlier namely Goodfellas and
casino which I actually watched after
finishing this uh and it does feel like
in a way these are a self-contained
trilogy like whether it was intended
that way or not but it is the great
three different looks at Reed and
criminality there's street level
illegality they're slightly more
legitimate yes still ma Brown
enterprises and then there is wolf of
Wall Street which although
funniest out of all of them is in some
ways the most impressive well also crime
gone legitimate the characters are so
he'll opinion on it yeah the characters
also a lot of people gone after this
movie about glorifying what these guys
are doing that is ridiculous yeah if
anyone thinks that they need to like
reach at themselves it's kind of scary
that anyone would say this it's the
people who win oh this Christian Bale
yeah they're Canseco to tell him you
know I am Patrick baby yeah it's it's um
it's interesting because this movie
after Goodfellas and Casino these
characters while being less violent or
almost more as despicable because
there's absolutely no sense of honor
what's so ever going yeah it's it's so
it's one of those like there's no honor
among thieves and there's especially no
honor among thieves in the financial
system i meanit's just watching the
downfall of this characters yeah and
it's the only thing you're there for
you're not there for twists and turns
it's such a direct journey yeah you know
you you basically know he's gonna go to
prison from frame 1 you know it's so it
is such a crazy world that is completely
by the way if you didn't know this was
based on a true story it would be this
unbelievably hacky fantastical yeah she
had unfair look at the financials and
apparently these people are monsters
like this and going into it knowing that
Jordan Belford was a consultant on the
movie he coached a cabrio and then
apparently they've weighed it down and
the other sentence to make it more
believable it is a really disconcerting
look and it's it's it's one of a
generation movies that I think we're
kind of conceived
like I mean not this movie's been
sitting around for a while DiCaprio had
the production rights are a couple years
but you know it really kicked into
production after the 2008 initial
collapse you know along with movies like
killing them softly miss was something
unpleasant to say about this aspect of
American life and it is it's unfortunate
that so much of the popular anger about
this has died down yeah time it's it's
taken to get those movies made because
these are this is a really effective
it's a straight to the mobilizing anger
it's an indictment how broken the
financial system is um just in in
closing we want to keep it kind of you
know we don't wanna get too out of hand
we could go on it we can talk for hours
about how great this movie is go see it
I just want to say this is news to no
one but the collaboration between Martin
Scorsese and his editor Thelma
Schumacher is one of the most exciting
ongoing collaborations I've ever seen
Mike and I think that like again
hopefully in 500 years when they're both
gone this will be remembered is like one
of the most important collaborations
because the enter the energy that exists
in his movies is all because of the
editing and like I mean obviously the
camera working but like the way that
they put these movies together has so
much to do with like the signature
Scorsese style yeah and it's really
really exciting to see two people who
are well into their 70s do experimenting
so much but form like this yeah
definitely so it just an incredible film
and I think it will only like a fine
wine it will only aged well yeah like a
fine wine or quaaludes it should aged
quite nice yes yes so go see it I mean
if you're if you're of the age that you
should go see kids don't see it this is
a very grand almost got an nc-17 yes
take that into a disturbance or so so
young boobs so many son that haven't
been said I mean amazing movie bear
worth seeing yes absolutely
really has recognized enough really has
a moral stance and it goes for it so
well we recommend it let's go sure coke
and wrestling money that's exactly what
I was planning on doing anyway Sam you
didn't have to tell me twice and so the
next time I'm Ryan I'm saying thank you
for watch